yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing sha hist a for the third time I
can try to transpose to that Slav
exchange and that worked works quite
often wonders yeah yeah did he really
realize that this is a born sac probably
not but it's not clear that this is some
just a pawn okay it's only did you
realize yeah I don't quite believe that
this can be enough compensation for
black but how do we play this he has
this Knight e4 Neji form idea maybe it's
that I have a hard time to develop the
c1 bishop so maybe I have to go for this
rather modest looking setup but it
should be possible to get to get the
pieces out anyway so here b3 it has a
bit of compensation yeah maybe my move
water wasn't that great
generally speaking Bishop b2 92 C form
is my idea but he has an ID form that is
definitely blacks idea now anyway there
is not a real I don't really have
anything else so let's do this and see
for next you know that should be the way
to go because c4 here I lose a bit of
time but I need to get this okay you two
get the b2 bishop traded yeah this looks
very natural
let's get this out of the C file that is
a good move actually
he has some compensation due to that we
can square on c3 if the pawn would be on
b2 here like here then I would have I
don't think I would have a fairly clear
extra pawn even that but but here the
night coming coming to c3 is a problem
ok I'm going for for this development
the reason is I want after Knight c3
and I cannot even do that I wanted to go
rook e1 and then rook c1 like a knight
c3 rook e1 he goes here I go here and
then this next but that would blunder a2
and that's a surprise
I thought here playing I'd see 3 years
was mandatory okay
more or less mandatory to get something
going at all now how do we do that
does he threaten anything I don't think
so so I can improve my position a little
bit getting the King closer don't see a
threat here maybe a whoopsie - could be
an idea double on the sea farm but this
is not a bad move I think I'm covering E
- in case of a future Knight c3 and
whatever circumstances this is useful
[Music]
yeah he wants to go D for it seems and
so this is a moment where it makes sense
to have the King here so that Knight c3
is not coming with the tempo if I now
capture or I kill it I can actually go
we'll go here immediately if v is
hanging twice is attacked twice and I
don't see how he covers it yeah he
doesn't now is he threatening anything
in particular group D - no covered
ninety-two I can probably just play King
you one
[Music]
okay and at night should go to deform
simply to pluck the D file 96 I go 94 I
simply return the porn
don't really mind to return this can
have that
the knight on d4 is just tying my whole
position together the next scumming
whoopsie two doubling doubling here it's
a he has pinned himself with the rook on
c5 and the bishop on c4 okay now is
there a way to immediately end the game
him this one maybe maybe and then Knight
a5 looks good I mean if he moves the
rook I can actually go to b5 that's that
stupid and then I've got a phone check
it took me a while to spot that but it's
wrong he's just winning the bishop 94
was quite good as well yeah okay
okay yeah I don't know he he definitely
had a good cool good game there at some
point I'm not sure if I wasn't trouble
on I mean okay let's let's go from from
the very beginning yeah I don't quite
believe that this is good you know I
mean okay the engine just gives a four
and says I'm clearly better it's
actually very true yeah you can also
just grab the center and claim that this
is just not a good opening which is yeah
that that's very very much true I get a
full scent and black has just problems
anyway okay I was greedy him and grabbed
the pawn so this is how he sacrificed it
and maybe now I should somehow improve I
mean the way it turned out it wasn't so
bad for him maybe III is too passive the
engine wants to go Knight bTW - and then
maybe e4 at the right moment
it's quite a fascinating suggestion you
form why it's that good just this one
yeah
hey it's nothing special but it's not
bad okay I went to e3 and I played it
quite conservatively but yeah the black
has some compensation and it's just just
quite which is the case okay the engine
is just firmly giving me plus one
maybe Queen B - where wasn't great an
engine now wants to go an IBD - and it's
quite yeah they say that's actually
really better am this way he never gets
to c3 yeah for example in a position
like that it's just really just a pawn I
mean he never gets to c3 so this wasn't
the most precise the engine still things
are better so maybe I was too concerned
down you know no I'm winning yeah maybe
I was too concerned I mean I'm always a
little bit wary of they get active play
yeah here I'm happy as I mentioned to
return the pawn I mean I don't
necessarily need to do that but if I get
the night to d4 this is just like a rock
yeah it just it plucks the D file it is
safely covered and the best that you can
do as we know and see for win the pawn
back and I don't really mind that as we
see in the game this kind of situation
is just very comfortable that Knight is
very stable and he's in himself and I
think the next moves um yeah he make it
a lot easier for me yeah Knight b3 I
think is good yeah he probably yeah I
don't I don't really know what you
should do to be honest I mean route b5
didn't work
the problem is that this is a lost
ending and we get to a King and pawn
ending with white being a pawn up that
is the win and yeah what else is there
if he goes here I'm gonna have 95 I mean
this and Knight a5 and if you go to see
several nights essentially it's not the
same then that's wrong but I just think
he cannot avoid the King and pawn ending
which should should be a win maybe um
maybe it's actually I mean I'm not
totally certain if he gets to c4 if the
King and pawn ending is a win like it's
very active there
I would probably maybe it's better to
insert this first and only then go here
or that blunders a - that would have
been embarrassing yeah okay it's not
it's not just not necessary I can always
play it in a slow way we don't need to
rush things
yeah okay guys thanks for watching